oh [ __ ]
look at you boy psychobabble and we're
playing the game we're playing a game
called lairs affair so our dough severe
Spanish first was really good and I
think we're just gotta jump right into
this [ __ ] okay I press any button to
continue
that's [ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] mana as a way
to that's my [ __ ] face
well did I gotta tell you did one thing
I was really excited about with this
game is how [ __ ] good the graphics
are oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is this game gonna
give me [ __ ] motion sickness and you
bet it is yeah notice it's a shower get
the [ __ ] away from me oh okay house I'm
very cat okay
can I help you taste a [ __ ] dump hope
I don't use too many of my reports okay
oh I like that control very smooth
anything in there
whoa okay I guess we're doing this batch
hey Jenny I'm us had at the Groupon deal
the unmooring act one okay okay okay
[ __ ] is this so long I got to finish
what was started and they lost yet here
we are okay
can I change this uh you just put all
the slides in there and it'll play
something and I got you and we're slides
around here no build the character
connect the memories prepare for the big
ro Act okay therefore that big row oh
it's beautiful out there
hello until a dispatch hopper settled in
all right I remember what we talked
about focus when you do best go to a
special place here's five the motivation
you're motivated build the character s
will be worth it um try keep in touch
office leave it for an agent so I'm just
like building a character I guess okay
that's cool app yet safe what is that
[ __ ] is that yeah testicles testicles
one two or three what is it
very nice I can't [ __ ] annoyed all
right anything I for we discover before
I venture out and match yourself up into
the wild let me take this real quick no
I get [ __ ] sick when the motion blur
oh [ __ ] there's all sorts of [ __ ] and
goodies in here okay okay
sure sugar to zoom and [ __ ] out here but
it's [ __ ] pretty
what is that okay that man okay
whoa is that a [ __ ] screaming dolphin
what the [ __ ]
okay okay that's capable that's camp
event well I tell it hello same traveler
I've been set up a request of Rios
delivered Icarus transl antic that seems
like gameplay real quick one sec let me
just let me just be a lost era here for
the fans okay for the fans
oh I can run I can run my favorite
should be padding there hello dolphin
okay so what's going on here is this
[ __ ] dope and I built the character
preparation explore Who am I where am I
you know [ __ ] Carnival Cruise I guess
right
it's very nice all this very nice very
expensive that's the only taste I have
is expensive
that's is okay
why don't I watching that sir
Shakespeare right now
hello mister
and I have fair
he must build the character he was meant
all right I don't want to get lost yeah
it's kind of quiet now
sad I know yeah how is this that I pay
for this I want a [ __ ] refund cancel
catsup Act one Dan Waring okay how's
that okay I guess through an act one
whoa this is weird
all right I guess the games begin seeing
travellers prediction crest section
super close with all passengers crew I
can't win the Icarus close that [ __ ]
and I'm an honor like [ __ ] it up
unroll a that's what I am closet I just
came on break-in [ __ ] that's it
yeah hey I have to weak my wrists are
too weak so is open No
[ __ ] is this yeah that's right well
that's gonna cool I'd like to now my
layers there's a fees second beautiful
it's [ __ ] emotion what's killing me
dude when you turn off that motion blur
I don't want [ __ ] now head
battlefield advanced motion blur okay
there we go
yeah finally your [ __ ] SEC I can say
segments already oh the whole [ __ ]
place is this is moving that's it
hello lady oh [ __ ] that I bailed inch
[ __ ] [ __ ]
open up locked what I pay you people for
I'm a [ __ ] actor it's beautiful
second beautiful Jesus
now I can add their you know I'm a
[ __ ] genius okay I mean I [ __ ]
them really course we open doors let me
tell you what is it really yeah French
restaurant
the elevators first-class paracin cafe
okay
can I help you sir [ __ ] dark juice up
in that [ __ ] [ __ ]
a lot of manual work here
but you can see through the mayor's okay
if I can help you sir
so I can piece of [ __ ] so this is get me
out of here where's my where's my server
all third-class passengers this way
please hey no [ __ ] at that class hello
Cyrus
[ __ ] thing is shaking I guess you can
figure out Moshe blush we can't think
that you can turn off the [ __ ] about
shaking and get [ __ ] sick you know he
[ __ ] sitting in bed not doing [ __ ]
just in my [ __ ] boxers and I'm gonna
[ __ ] vomit ain't that the [ __ ]
greatest holy [ __ ] on a stack well it's
so [ __ ] wet in here so I'm gonna get
off I need I feel like I [ __ ] need
like a towel from secured office that
the chief never seen enforce procedures
or enforce personís of proud of the
guards power incidents vessels making
their unwanted individuals on their
vessels stowaways so the biggest threat
to them is stowaways stow away in here
where the [ __ ] are the stowaways no
stowaways in there just always in here
okay nothing to kind of call down here
all right let's had some [ __ ] staus
keep reeling it's a take on my [ __ ]
leg but I would never let that happen so
just that way in here all right
press y to crouch
how canst always where are you [ __ ] SS
head wearing cut that out not [ __ ]
stowaway I see him well is that the
[ __ ] painting from the first game I
think it is
holy [ __ ] wait the hope there's so many
[ __ ] doors oh let me just make sure I
can't go in here I can't okay
[ __ ] running what's in there
a hammer that's fine I guess let's let
us come in less okay dot dot dot dot dot
and okay
now that that yeah I tried try but I'm
not perfect so I get this disgusting
clothes that have the same deal yeah
that get clothes that house down that
this game gonna be a lot of doors it's
gonna be a lot of doors in this game
suck CEO okay
oh I like the sound of this
- [ __ ]
[ __ ] I got that I got sick on this one
all right
no they [ __ ] got me
what's going on in here all right the
meals ready now that was in our MK X but
you know I am the captain now
[ __ ] is that mist [ __ ] that miss
coming from you see that the [ __ ] is
that
okay he's got a reputation jump through
hoops before even what's him on the set
supposed to be some new method of
building the character bunch of artsy
fartsy [ __ ] if you ask me just go
with it guy doesn't take no for an
answer
we're in a Manchester it's [ __ ]
rolling what the [ __ ] is going on here
how did that I mean now
I'm on the other side down is I'm sort
of chassis about oh I'm the one that did
it
no this is all part of the plan still
quiet now once you're aware how I would
much picture going to s whole restricted
for regular just don't start the film
well thank you just [ __ ] doubt wait I
saw something what else I just keep
playing with it okay it's not gonna let
me do this doors the [ __ ] was that
now see secrets walk backwards now
yes my name is Marc Anthony I was Marc
Anthony oh dear hung in D the [ __ ] or
just in this [ __ ] room any more notes
Sonya tried to be a part of my greatest
work as if there was ever a choice only
you only one gonna bring it the one
who's broken up the belt okay thank ya
well he sounded my check so am I is that
gonna break [ __ ] just had that take a
rolling camera or something I'm mr.
sunshine okay let's do this well
way too [ __ ] quiet in here yeah [ __ ]
that
ahoy mateys
the [ __ ] is that we should have thought
[Music]
[ __ ] of that hey take a clue here
alright guess there's no clap
they [ __ ] got me [ __ ] trapped six
extinct okay there we go
hell yeah brother I'm gonna [ __ ] die
what is that a napkin how am i sad ciao
oh yeah I kinda the [ __ ] is this how do
I get laying on that that square come on
I'm we're come on
peddler
the [ __ ]
okay that's got it yet hell yeah brother
[ __ ]
ding-ding-ding
I'm rather Stewart Oh Lady Toledo sorry
sorry Adam's apple
wait where that [ __ ] head go
he just had a [ __ ] ad where it go
hello sorry not mind me
tough [ __ ] I say and I get over there
these images memories of you
they've been haunting ricetec why I
stick what I forgot that
whoa
okay stand here
okay all right keep going I feel like I
need more preparation for this
thank God I'm vice hell [ __ ] oh that's
cigarettes don't mind if I do
okay can get messy in here baby [ __ ]
scary ass game okay and I put the
foreskin I mean foreplay how does
[ __ ] talking right now
whoa
yeah I guess we're just doing this why
don't use the outside I feel like if we
have the same scenery might as well use
that and it's got [ __ ] left
[Music]
as [ __ ] are we supposed to go that way
yeah [ __ ] I done [ __ ] up now it's how
I gotta say that's in here scurvy the
scariest one I'll just [ __ ] [ __ ] a
cannon
[Music]
okay I'm ringing it
oh holy [ __ ] I can't scare every what's
on there now no I can't get down there
now only during the scene can I go down
there actor announcement that's what I
gotta say [ __ ] locked again I just
love like a Thursday now I'm the [ __ ]
star anything [ __ ] locked my trailer
better you ready great
yeah
made-to-order sturdy wooden chests oak
larger the fit of grown man well I
wasn't [ __ ] black and white nice
office
it's [ __ ] lap just break my
concentration what is this
no ooh
that's character are you ready to go
back it's [ __ ] character everyone
[ __ ] knows that everyone [ __ ]
knows that
be ready to go back so I'm going back
then right
[ __ ] is that
everything is fine
oh it's glutes okay
hey where they go you're [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I'm trained in the theater press I'll be
to run the [ __ ] is having
that's that 1080 40 okay I just say
frowny I [ __ ] know it
oh yes oh yeah
1080 40
[ __ ] dark in here where's the [ __ ]
safe
where's the mayonnaise
ten
that's isn't a safe yeah we go this is
the rail safe 1080i already [ __ ] do
that turn all the way to 10 turn it all
the way to 80 take it the 40 No
turn it right to 10 and let go
oh yeah baby [ __ ] seashells that piece
of [ __ ] no thank you
hey starways in here what mr. hardy is a
quartermaster there's a very important
thing to be because the quartermaster
takes care of each other the crew needs
to be well below make sure there's
plenty of food around birth would charge
very loyal to captain always falls will
up mr. Hardy
sometimes gets across the campus another
could cross the majority but that's only
because he cares currently with the
whole crew the truth is what the [ __ ] an
eft if I can read that garbage that's a
it's got on over here any more than I
need the place
[ __ ] yeah I got 111
very quiet in here
I mean something's gonna break where's a
jump-scare uh-hum I said there there's a
[ __ ] door
yeah go this what the [ __ ] dude this is
definitely reference to the shining
because the floor and the bicycles
I'm sure look at me I'm just a mouse
that gets here
tough [ __ ] someone's got to pick up
their trash hello sorry
this fellow is wise enough to play the
fool okay thank you okay that's a
compliment where's my free swag [ __ ]
does anything mean okay
the [ __ ] is that
should I happy I say okay I can do that
oh that's the key it's the king take
that thank you
[ __ ] bright Jesus [ __ ] chocolate
recording
boom-shaka-laka thingie I got you a
sucker I'm [ __ ] perfect that's how
you want me to sum all right yeah that
was like nothing I could do this all day
wait was that a hole go to
[ __ ] I'd say that shots going through
all the walls that's crazy
oh I [ __ ] it and I'm pretty good I
don't know is that good that's chicken
China Brooke here we go
alright I'll pay for the [ __ ] wall
the [ __ ] I didn't do those I'm not
paying for [ __ ] those I'll get some
[ __ ] spackle that's about it shut
okay I don't think it stopped around
here we're good guys chat now just
kidding keep God
there's definitely [ __ ] jump-scare
here [ __ ] knew it
[ __ ] knew it Kenny gone to us now
hello sir hello sir you could use a fan
to cool off nope ain't playing that game
there's this batch
whoa
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] it's like
Stanley Kubrick reference or something
Oh [ __ ] disgusting okay
[Music]
I'm gonna forget it
yeah tell me twice yeah don't gotta tell
me twice
yeah just hello sir Thomas get the [ __ ]
out of here [ __ ]
yeah only one of us knows what she done
only one knows with the state yet that
doesn't need to know doesn't it tell us
an act that's what I thought that's a
director that everyone Nate's [ __ ]
mouth outside going crazy
I should probably blink warn these games
you know these things are really
stopping from blinking I should shut the
[ __ ] up
so these are the stowaways
[ __ ] me a free letter so
quick see when I don't know what to do I
just [ __ ] I just suck and pull
switches anywhere jumps guys here I
[ __ ] know it
step ahead
time and tide wait for no man okay so
maybe I should I let that guy touch me
Oh didn't work wait okay
I want you at the [ __ ] run perfect i
sorry I think i'ma skill sucking sucking
my blood sure in a sec today thank you
I'll have to see
[ __ ] I ain't waiting for that I suppose
we close these doors behind me I'm not
doing that just [ __ ] around in the
[ __ ] is this how [ __ ] better pay me
more
I found doing my own [ __ ] stunts that
Gators oh [ __ ] I got the real baby I got
it a lot of my say that's kid
fucking-a
there's this man
the [ __ ] is that there's like a word
intro
[Applause]
testicles testicles one two three
and I shall wear I got all the stuff I
need baby I got all the stuff I did my
pictures up yet yeah [ __ ] yeah well I
[ __ ] a lot already
oh [ __ ] actually now I guess these are
all swats for it
how about dolphin you shoe it outside
looks like I know what the [ __ ] this is
sorry I didn't get any nice bucks the
[ __ ] is that
okay
no I just got that that's sick another
[ __ ] word is character put the mask
on unmask said every actors part they're
going to play with the bill blah blah
Church you face it's [ __ ] characters
that [ __ ] the mask
my [ __ ] mask wait am I sick there's
so many dresses here recording I'm gonna
check it can't [ __ ] tell anyway I
guess it's act 1 so we'll see you on the
next episode
hope y'all shut thank you very much I'll
do it make sure what this has altered a
good stark lad to hear you in the
director get it long to keep what you
doing get this in the can no time all
right all right all right
what is a year in here no okay thanks
for watching yell see ya on the next
episode